[Musica]
[Applauso]
ieri grazie poco e quello che mi fa
piacere ci sono tanti ragazzi quando
iniziamo in sala più il ragazzo più gli
adulti è viva e mi sento un po a casa
mia perché a questo io doveva essere a
scuola io devo ringraziare il disagio il
disagio e vi ha portato qua io sono una
persona normalissima che semplicemente
vuole vivere il suo tempo non solo con
dignità ma con pienezza
sono una donna di scuola sono andata a
scuola e tutti quelli che sono andati a
scuola sono qui e io mi preoccupo di
quelli che non ci vanno
e poi non li troviamo qui e li troviamo
altrove e non dobbiamo aspettare tutto
questo tempo per portarli dentro
ecco io e ho avuto tante tante
esperienze nel volontariato e mi
occupavo del disagio non so se qualcuno
di voi conosce il casertano l'aria
domiziano e castelvolturno dove
ammazzarlo tutte quelle persone
immigrate eccetera io mi occupavo dei
figli delle prostitute e loro mi hanno
ispirato e dissero a me mentre io mi
occupavo di come poter arginare quel
fenomeno
fai qualcosa per mio figlio io faccio
questo perché devo sopravvivere
quelle parole negli ormai dimenticate
poi mi è capitato di vincere il concorso
da dirigente scolastico non volevo
accettare perché mi occupavo già di
tanto disagio in altri ambienti per
odyssey tutti si lamentano la scuola non
funziona
il professore non sempre all'altezza e
la scuola sgarrupata di come io devo
andare a vedere da vicino e accettai
quel luogo perché nessuno
sapevo che nessuno voleva la viviani che
era una scuola di primo ciclo ma io
sapevo che c'erano dei problemi non
immaginavo tanti e quando io scelsi
quella scuola mi applaudirono tutti una
liberazione
solo mio marito non mia applauditissima
per opera
tutti questo è una bellissima scuola c'è
qualcosa che non va e c'era qualcosa che
non andava
io arrivo il 13 luglio del 2007 arrivò a
caivano parco verde e la scuola dove io
dovevo agire era chiusa ed erano
arrivati tanti soldi ma dicevano che
devono fare le varianti e poi chi mi ha
preceduto
era andato nella succursale perché
aspettava sempre ragazzi io non ho mai
visto tanto disordine ville e materassi
tutto tutto tutto sembrava tramite la
scuola dal colera bella è un bel pezzo
di cemento tutto colorato all'esterno e
ricordo l'ho detto a piu parti una
donnina con una scopa che togli valle le
foglie in mezzo a questo viale 13 luglio
del 2007 il silenzio mi colpì non c'era
un anima viva
eppure erano lì le 11 del mattino
andai nella succursale e militante i
collaboratori scolastici tutti
abbronzati coni mollettoni tutti i
liberisti felici
chiesi di andare in bagno perché voi
dovete essere furbi ragazzi la civiltà
comincia dalla tua lenza arriva in lei
c'erano dei nomi dei probabilmente dei
prof
il mio armadietto quella firma e con le
catene il bagno era sporco la pipì si
sblocca ritorno non dico che ero il
preside che ero stato nominato da poco e
mi io chiesi del prete non c'è il
vicepreside nun c'ha il collaborato
termo tutti quasi inferi c'era una
ragazza che con i capelli al vento
sistemava le carte di sì
e quando arrivano a non lo so insomma
una collaboratrice molto molto furbetta
capi qualcosa di sé ma mica io ho visto
le nomine voi siete la presse che deve
venire in questa scuola dico dove la
sola centrale era nel parco verde dico
io sto zitta tu se dite accompagnami io
ho visto catene materassi anche li dico
ma dove sono capitata mio marito
ammutolito dice dice a me mio marito
chi ti do e la presidenza sai la moglie
che diventa preside la prima cosa che
cosa avete
la presidenza i libri per ragazzi tutto
questo non l'ho incontrato non ha fatto
niente
ho fatto quello che un comune cittadino
deve fare ho cominciato a pulire ad
urlare a chiedere aiuto
il silenzio tombale man mano che io
andava avanti in 15 giorni per lo meno
ap il varco per entrarci poi ragazzi
sono passati tanti anni l'ho li pulita
con quali fondi mi dicono lo ripulita
con quelli che avevano lo stipendio e
non lavoravano era la scuola dei
supplenti
perché nessuno ci voleva andare ovvero
anche a destra nel se lui si vuol venire
e perché non ci vole non si vuole andare
lì perché il disagio è talmente alto che
non ti senti all'altezza
pensi di andare a trasmettere un
contenuto ma lì non devi andare per
trasmettere un contenuto
tu devi andare lì e dire che c'è da fare
e questo ho fatto per lunghi anni
all'inizio recall qualcuno mi applaudiva
tutti erano felici andava man mano che
andava avanti le cose sono diventate
sempre più difficile perché il mio sogno
è semplicemente quello di aiutarvi a
pensare gli altri non vogliono più tu
pensi perché se tu pensi ci pensi un po
a far quel che loro vogliano e allora ho
ottenuto mi ero illusa di andare a tanti
a tante case importanti dai facciamo
mettiamo sul tempo prolungato il tempo
pieno il genio ma questa che vuole più
facevo questo più toglieva la
manovalanza più entravano in merito più
mi sentivo contestata dalle mamme perché
io me li andava a prendere a casa perché
come è nato questo primo mito di andare
a prendere i ragazzi a casa
sai lino né che avevo e olio un tasso di
dispersione altissimo e dico che faccia
stamattina
noi ce ne andiamo non c'è nessuno di
come tu dove vai e vieni pagato
aspettami un attimo fu la disperazione
in tra i viali e cominciare a vedere
qualche ragazzino mio sui balconi e
cominciai a dire maria scendi ma che fai
la
vieni anche qua pool e giuseppe non si
vuole alzare e la gente che ti dice
entra a casa mia
quella gente che non ha visto mai la
gioia di essere o di sentirsi persona
che il massimo che ti può capitare
e tu da che parte vai da quella parte ho
conosciuto momenti duro conosciuto le
minacce ma che vi vengo a raccontare le
minacce che ho avuto io manco me le
ricordo il tempo mi ha dato la
possibilità di urlare e quanto ero lì lì
per essere riuscita a voleva un
verticalizzato una scuola che mi potesse
consentire di accompagnarli fino alla
maturità
forse non è che tutti vogliono non c'è
l'aspirazione diventare ingegnere ai
ragazzi tutti aspirano a diventare
ingegneri la il massimo dell'aspirazione
delle ragazzine fare la l'estetista le
unghie capelli e allora immaginate che
cosa noi andiamo a mettere in tv che la
ragazzina è felice se diventa bella e
dimenticando la sua bellezza e ho
cominciato a dire togliti i tacchi porto
i tacchi per una semplice ragione perché
una mattina questa ve la voglia di
raccontare i primi giorni quando gli
sono arrivati ha cominciato a pulire a
fare di tutto e di più
io arrivo i ragazzi non hanno abituato
con i succhi di frutti mi divisero le
pareti tutti che buttavano le carte per
terra ti stimiamo che faccio e tutto è
iniziato lì l'idea di renderli
responsabili e tu poi comincia ad
insistere e bevi cambiamenti ma più
facevo questo più rin debbo debole colui
il quale non voleva il cambiamento
quando poi ho cominciato ad urlare un
poco di più a mettere megafoni sulla
scuola perché non si svegliavano più
facevo questo più i nemici aumentano
come si è chiusa la prima mia storia
si è chiusa molto male in una realtà
come quella di parco verde che non c'era
bisogno del video
andatevela a vedere che cos'è avevo
bisogno
di far tirare tirare fuori la bellezza e
quindi ho investito tanto sulla
impeccabilità dell'accoglienza a
convincere professore a crederci e loro
mi hanno gi tito facendomi un
provvedimento di chiusura giuridica sa
in tre luoghi difficili come quelle le
scuole devono diventare di più tu devi
mettere una scuola in ogni angolino
ma che dici anno camuffato per non far
sentire che abbiamo avevano mandata via
mi fanno il trasferimento a questo
istituto superiore da francesca morana e
anche lì ho trovato 15 aule di tutto
tuttosport abbiamo ricominciato a pulire
ragazze lo sapete che questa è stata la
cosa più bella
non ci vuole niente a pulire ma poi io
volevo di più perché lo scempio è che
tutti sapevano e nessuno faceva e io mi
sono messa lì e quando doveva invece
riappropriarmi dello spazio del custode
che si era presa di quello del bar che
l'aveva occupato tutto questo ho
cominciato anche a scrivere in modo
forte e ho cominciato anche a immaginare
che qualche magistrato qualcuno qualche
procuratore
qualche volta le carte le legge adesso
tutti mi vogliono dare le cose non sono
contenta perché allora era un atto
dovuto a voi ragazzi che cosa posso
raccontare che quello che è capitato a
me
può capitare anche a voi la mia venuta
qua significa che c'è un sentiero ci
sono tante luci che sta accendendo i
miei ragazzi sto tentato di portarlo in
tutta italia sono i migliori ragazzi del
mondo io ve lo posso dire con tutto il
cuore
voi non sapete che cosa ci hanno dentro
però loro la mattina ti sorridono molta
gente non sorride più
e voi invece anche nel disagio vedete
genti che felice mica deve dire quante
macchine a casa quello deve dire devo
arrivare presto perché mamma non c'è e
devo lavorare per mamma e c'è quello che
ti dice 50 euro vieni qua e ti da quella
50 ore 50 euro e ti distrugge per la
vita
io voglio semplicemente dire a voi
grazie perché io
venendo qui ho acceso un'altra luce
io vorrei che i ragazzi miei quando si
dovessero presentare qui a treviso a
milano come sto realizzando questo mio
viaggio e quella scuola sono quelle
regole che hanno reso libero il mio
ragazzo ragazzi dobbiamo metterci
insieme dobbiamo essere capaci di non
emozionarsi di fronte al disagio ma
dobbiamo riaccendere la voglia e la
speranza con che cosa facendo dobbiamo
prendere quella carta
dobbiamo dire a chi dice che fu pensar
per noi che noi possiamo pensare per
loro dobbiamo chiudere un po i
telefonini si sono importanti le
tecnologie ecc
ci dobbiamo riabbracciare un attimo
dobbiamo riconnetterci perché voi oggi
non avete il telefonino state sentendo
me e io credo che chi sa cosa ho detto
in questo momento io vi posso dire che
il cambiamento può esserci puoi esserci
con un semplice gesto a volte anche uno
sguardo anche un incontro anche facendo
capire che l'indifferenza ammazza le
persone l'omertà ammazza di persone
i muri a volte sono fisici noah volte ci
sono dei muri quelli da invisibili
quelli del silenzio sono ancora più
pericolosi
abbiate il coraggio di non far finta di
niente rispetto al problema
abbiate il coraggio di dire al compagno
guarda io sono bella lite c'entra il
trucco guarda abbiate il coraggio che se
ti buchi e finita queste cose vanno
dette
ma se invece voi ve li fate sempre
raccontare e voi fate finta di
emozionarvi quando vedete un immagine
per televisione e poi casomai non vi
comportate bene con la signora affianca
che non dite bongiorno questo è il mio
credo io credo nei piccoli gesti
io credo nelle piccole cose sto cercando
di convincere i prof perché i prof
molte volte dicono sono dall'università
del 1800 la storia
molte volte ci vuole semplicemente un
abbraccio e tutto si scioglierà sapete
come no io non mi devo dire come si
conquista una pistola e guardando negli
occhi alle persone che lo si può
conquistare
io vedo ho visto una bellezza
è incredibile ho pensato a questo
alberghiero ieri sera il mio l'ho fatto
a pezzettini ogni pezzettino milan
molti me li regalo a me mi hanno fatto
di tutto è i catene pitbull e 14 pitbull
per non farmi entrare in quel palazzo
l'ho preso l'ho riabilitato quella
cucina non me l'ha comprata una città
metropolitana con una questo abbiamo
vendute le pizzette le fettuccine il
pani fatta dalle mamme quel palazzo è il
palazzo dei sacrifici e io sono convinta
che palazzo i miei ragazzi non lo
faranno toccare ma se anche voi ci
mettete un po di vostro accendendo dice
se succede qualcosa che a ivan io
scenderò in piazza quando sono stata
mandata via
non c'era un cane in mezzo alla strada
io amo una canzone vincerò è bellissima
e loro me l'hanno privata ascoltare
ho perso un po di chili in quel periodo
non riuscivo a camminare
ho visto una mia ragazza c'è quarta
preside
io sono qui aiutami arrivare quella
ragazza
oggi l'ho fatta a sostenere da due
persone molto importanti di roma è
arrivata in quinta e l'unica ragazza di
meccanica meccatronica ha una storia
incredibile voleva fare il maschietto è
una bellissima ragazza perché lei si
voleva difendere perché immaginiamo che
il maschio possa difendersi no è la
donna e l'uomo che si devono difendere
insieme oggi è diplomata e a case di
persone due figli straordinarie si
lavorerà e io spero di dare quel mio
istituto a qualche mio ragazzo non lo
voglio lasciare al territorio è troppo
debole non è pronto perché se era pronto
avrebbe difeso quel territorio
quando questi ragazzi io cercherò di
aumentare il numero dei laureati
penseranno e quel fazzoletto di terra
quel piccolo angolino di terra diventerà
la speranza non per parco verde per
l'italia per voi non si può venire qua e
vedere l'opulenza e la perfezione io
credo che anche qui c'è qualche cosa che
non va e allora mettiamoci
e facciamo diventare belletti speranza
semplicemente un gesto
questo è quello che faccio mille di più
[Musica]
[Applauso]
io non sono social ma c'è una mia
assistente che ha detto presto è un modo
per far sapere quello che noi siamo e
questo applauso non l'avete fatto a me a
tanti ragazzi e io un giorno vorrei
arrivare con un bastoncino e vederli qui
al posto mio
ricordatevi che si può cambiare e lo
dico con il cuore
grazie grazie grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]